that report from DW Charlotte shall
simple and she's standing by for us in
Genoa hi Charlotte
a rescue work continued for a second
night is there still hope that anyone
can still be found alive hi sue me yes
rescue workers with the help of sniffer
dogs have been combing through the
wreckage that's just behind me for a
second night we've heard though that
they've found nobodies no survivors this
was an extremely fruitless search last
night we know that a number of people
are still missing one of the big issues
though is it's not exactly clear how
many authorities aren't certain for
example how many cars were on the bridge
at the time of the collapse so it's
possible that any number of people could
still be buried in the wreckage behind
me is that that's motivating rescue
workers to continue their search here
they've told us that they will keep
looking until they are absolutely
convinced that no one is still alive
below us of course though as time goes
on it's becoming more and more likely
that they will find bodies rather than
survivors sure as we saw in your report
you know there's a lot of anger and the
Italian government looks set to revoke
the highway operators permit as well
what if some of the reactions been to
that well the company itself has reacted
to that it's as I've mentioned in the
reports stated categorically that its
maintenance checks were up to date it's
also pointed out that it hasn't been
proven yet that it had any direct
responsibility for the collapse of this
bridge it's also been pointed out that
it's very complicated to revoke the
license for this company that this the
company would be entitled to some sort
of compensation for breaking the
contract now people here are more than
aware exactly how complicated the task
ahead will be they're very conscious
that if this if the autostrada isn't
managing the bridge behind me who will
be so there is no real appeasement for
the anger here after this announcement
by your authorities they know as well
that this is going to be in very long
process ahead when it comes to
rebuilding the bridge that's collapsed
they know that this is a huge
infrastructure here in Genoa and it's
not exactly clear what's going to happen
to traffic for example that's might not
sound like a big issue but this was
vital for this city here and it could
lead to chaos for the months and the
weeks ahead and what about for residents
there Charlotte you know 12-month state
of emergency has been put in place in
the region
how are people they're going to be
affected yeah that's something that was
requested by a regional austerities here
now in practice this state of emergency
isn't like something that you may have
heard of in France for example after the
Paris terror attacks where you saw
military on the streets to deal with
this crisis this means in practice that
more funding will be available to deal
with the catastrophe it's been announced
that initially 5 million euros has been
freed up to deal with what's ahead it
just means basically the litzer
authorities and the government can make
decisions faster because they know that
there is a long road ahead to getting
this city back into a state that's
that's functional for example the just
below me on the bridge the it collapsed
on to a recycling depot again might seem
like a small thing but it means that's
the the recycling in the city is going
to be affected as well there is still a
very long process ahead
all right DW Charlotte shall simple
reporting for us from Genoa Sharla thank
you